Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the second part of our episode on the events of 1968. And we are literally in Paris. We're in the heart of the Latin Quarter, where the students all kicked off. Today, we're going to continue sitting in the cafe, continue our chat. We're going to be heading off to the Champs-Élysées. And it is all thanks to WISE, the international account that is built to save you money around the world. Whether it's with a card or your phone, you can spend like a local Dominic.
感谢收听《历史的 restis》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com，并收听我们关于 1968 年事件的下半集。我们现在身处巴黎。我们在拉丁区的中心，这里是学生们最初发起抗议的地方。今天，我们将继续坐在咖啡馆里，继续我们的闲聊。我们将前往香榭丽舍大街。这一切都要感谢 WISE，这个旨在为你在全球省钱的国际账户。无论是用卡还是通过手机，你都可以像当地人一样消费，多米尼克。
Have I ever said that before? I think I might have done. In 150 countries? Have I mentioned that as well? Always. 150 countries. Brilliant, Tom. So you may remember, dear listeners,
我以前说过这话吗？我想我大概说过。在 150 个国家？我也提到过这个吗？总是如此。150 个国家。太棒了，汤姆。所以亲爱的听众们，你们可能还记得，
that last time we were talking about the events of May 1968, we were talking about the outbreak of the student protests à Nanterre, outside Paris, about the way in which they spread to the heart of the left bank, to the Sorbonne, the overreaction of the French authorities, the violence of the police,
上次我们讨论 1968 年 5 月的事件时，我们谈到了巴黎郊外南泰尔学生抗议活动的爆发，谈到了它们蔓延到左岸中心、索邦大学的方式，法国当局的过度反应，警察的暴力，
the violence of the students in response, the sense that the government had lost control, then the wave of strikes, and we ended by saying... And two-thirds of the country is on strike. Two-thirds of the country is on strike. And this sort of sense that...
作为回应，学生的暴力行为，政府失去控制的感觉，然后是罢工浪潮，我们的结语是……整个国家有三分之二的人在罢工。整个国家有三分之二的人在罢工。这种感觉……
Well, revolution is in the air, Tom, I suppose you would say. And the man we haven't really talked about very much... It's the general himself. It's the general himself, the president of France. He's been president...
好吧，空气中弥漫着革命的气息，汤姆，我想你会这么说。而我们还没有真正多谈论的那个人……正是将军本人。正是将军本人，法国总统。他一直是总统……
I mean, you quoted that line, didn't you, last time? What's it, 10 years? That's enough. Yeah. That people were chanting. So de Gaulle, he's been in power for 10 years,
我的意思是，你上次引用过那句话，不是吗？什么来着，10 年？这就够了。是的。人们在齐声高呼。所以戴高乐，他已经执政 10 年了，
but of course his career is so much longer so for those people who don't know de gaulle was born in the northeast of france in lille in 1890 he served with distinction in the first world war he was captured by the germans at verdun at the great kind of symbolic showdown of the of the french and german armies he in 1940, the embodiment of French resistance to the occupation. Of course, he went to England, famously not a great fan of England or the English, I think it's fair to say, Tom. And then he came back, famously, marches down the Champs-Élysées, where we'll be later, in the liberation in 1944, and claims that France has liberated itself. Doesn't want to give any credit to the Americans or British. Any credit at all.
但当然他的职业生涯要长得多，所以对于那些不知道的人来说，戴高乐于 1890 年出生在法国东北部的里尔，他在第一次世界大战中表现卓越，在凡尔登战役——法国和德国军队之间那种具有重大象征意义的对决中被德国人俘虏，他在 1940 年成为了法国对占领抵抗的化身。当然，他去了英国，众所周知，他并不是英国或英国人的超级粉丝，我觉得这样说很公道，汤姆。然后他回来了，众神皆知地，在 1944 年的解放中沿着我们待会儿会去的香榭丽舍大街游行，并宣称法国解放了自己。不想给美国人或英国人任何功劳。哪怕一点点功劳也不给。
Which is all part of his belief in the glory of France. He knows that's a bit of a fiction, but he thinks it's a necessary fiction for France to be itself. And then he very briefly runs France from 1944 to 1946, but he's impatient with parliamentary politics. He's not cut out for it. And then he disappears into retirement. But then in 1950... Columnie des Egl in the sort of la france profonde yeah it's in the heart of france at colombia this is the place that gives him his mystical connection
这完全符合他对法兰西荣耀的信仰。他知道这有点虚构，但他认为这是法兰西成为法兰西所必需的虚构。然后他在 1944 年至 1946 年非常短暂地管理法国，但他对议会政治没有耐心。他不是那块料。然后他退隐了。但随后在 1950 年……位于某种“深层法国”的科隆布代莱德格尔，是的，它在法国的腹地科隆布，这个地方赋予了他与法兰西灵魂、普通法国民众之间神秘的联系，
to the soul of france to ordinary french men and women and it's partly because he has this supposed mystical connection that in 1958 when france has got itself into a terrible mess in algeria there's a coup effectively the fourth republic is replaced by the fifth republic and de gaulle comes in as a pretty autocratic president because the fifth republic enshrines the president as basically a monarch as a monarch he's filling that king-shaped hole in the French constitution. Exactly, exactly. And de Gaulle is also,
部分正是因为他有着这种所谓神秘的联系，所以才在 1958 年法国在阿尔及利亚陷入极其糟糕的烂摊子时，实际上发生了一场政变，第四共和国被第五共和国取代，戴高乐作为一位相当专制的总统登台，因为第五共和国将总统实质上奉为君主，作为君主，他填补了法国宪法中那个国王形状的空缺。没错，没错。而且戴高乐还，
I mean, he's not just the personification of France and French patriotism. He's also the personification of what we talked about last time, which was that paternalistic, patriarchal, sort of quite authoritarian public culture that governs French life more generally.
我的意思是，他不仅是法国和法兰西爱国主义的化身。他也是我们上次讨论的事物的化身，即那种对法国生活更广泛地进行统治的、家长式的、父权制的、某种程度上相当威权主义的公共文化。
You know, the general. Everybody looks up to the general, the president. But he has, I mean, famously, he has a certain sense of France. Yeah. And he means that in an almost mystical sense. The idea that there is a French identity that transcends the actual lived reality of people who live in France. Yes.
你知道，将军。每个人都仰望将军，总统。但他确实，我的意思是，众所周知，他对法国有一种特定的观念。是的。而且他是在一种近乎神秘的意义上这样认为的。那种认为存在着一种超越法国实际生活之人的现实的法兰西身份的想法。是的。
To a degree. Yes, absolutely. And his sense of France, I think think does not include poets and mime artists long-vading university bill no definitely doesn't involve long hair so you may ask well what's he doing doing all this so his first reaction is that this is just childishness and he says to his ministers uh the 5th of may when a child gets angry and oversteps the mark the best way of calming him down is by giving him a smack so excellent um parenting advice very good parenting advice two days later he's been sent a petition by french nobel prize winners telling him to go easy on the students and to give the students what they want and he is enraged by this and he says to his ministers you seem terrorized
某种程度上。是的，绝对是。而他对法国的理解，我认为不包括在大学里散发传单的诗人和哑剧演员——不，绝对不包括长头发。所以你可能会问，那他在干什么呢？所以他的第一反应是这只是小孩子气，他在 5 月 5 日对他的部长们说，当一个孩子生气并越界时，让他平静下来的最好方法就是给他一巴掌。所以，真是极好的育儿建议，非常好的育儿建议。两天后，他收到了一份由法国诺贝尔奖得主发给他的请愿书，让他们对学生手下留情，并满足学生的要求，他对此大发雷霆，并对他的部长们说，你们在这些孩子面前显得惊恐万分，不要忘记内政部长必须知道如何在必要时下达开枪的命令。所以他嘴里蹦出这些非常凶狠的话，但实际上，当然，他知道这永远不会（你知道，没有人会付诸行动），在某些情况下，我认为格雷戈实际上是瘫痪了，他不知道该怎么办，他真的与现实脱节了。我的意思是，他实际上是一个非常有文化修养的人，他总是竭尽全力阅读最新的小说，紧跟最新的文化发展，但他已经七十多年代了，是的，到 20 世纪 60 年代末，出于完全可以理解的原因，他与法国人的情绪脱节了，而且瑞士人也在对照戴高乐所体现的那种爱国主义理想来定义自己，这对他来说一定感到十分困惑。绝对是，确实如此。
in front of these children do not forget that a minister of the interior must know how if necessary to give the order to fire so he's he's coming out with this very sort of ferocious stuff but actually of course he knows that this will never you know no one's going to act on this and in some ways i think gregor is actually paralyzed he doesn't know what to do he's really out of touch i mean he's actually a very literate and very cultivated man who goes out who's always gone out of his way to read the latest fiction to be up with you know the latest cultural developments but he's in his mid-70s yeah and by the late 1960s for completely understandable reasons he is out of touch with the mood in the in french but also the the swiss are defining themselves against the kind of ideals of of patriotism that de gaulle embodies and that must be bewildering to him absolutely it is
绝对是，确实如此。
absolutely so as you said he's been off to romania on a state visit he insists on going ahead with this visit to romania well because he's very keen isn't't he, on situating France between the NATO and the Warsaw Pact. And Ceausescu in Romania is a kind of slightly loose cannon. Yeah. I mean, to a degree. And so he's kind of hoping to convert Ceausescu to a Gaullist understanding. I think it's fair to say Nicolae Ceausescu is not a friend of the rest of history. No, not at all.
所以，正如你所说，他去了罗马尼亚进行国事访问，他坚持要继续这次罗马尼亚之行，嗯，因为他非常热衷于将法国定位在北约和华沙条约组织之间，对吧。而罗马尼亚的齐奥塞斯库是一个有点像脱缰野马的人物。是的。从某种程度上讲。所以他有点希望把齐奥塞斯库拉拢到戴高乐主义的理解上来。我觉得这样说很公道：尼古拉·齐奥塞斯库不是《历史的 restis》的朋友。不，一点也不是。
So, yeah, right, exactly. De Gaulle has been to Romania. He returns to France on the 18th of May. And he says, you know, he's been, when in Romania, by the way,
所以，没错，确实如此。戴高乐去过罗马尼亚。他于 5 月 18 日返回法国。他说，你知道，他在罗马尼亚的时候，顺便说一句，
he hasn't been sleeping. He's been lying awake at night, sort of, full of anxiety about what's going, what on earth is going on in Paris. He returns and he says, this anarchy is absolutely nonsense, and he calls it famously,
他一直没有睡觉。他夜不能寐，某种程度上，充满了对巴黎究竟发生了什么、到底在搞什么鬼的焦虑。他归来后说，这种无政府状态简直是一派胡言，他用了一个著名的词，
chienlit. Which is a dog has shat in the bed basically so it's soiling the bed yeah which is obviously not i mean it's a very famous remark but it's not best calculated to endear him to the student protesters because basically i mean the way of translating i suppose would be to say they're bed wetters they're wetting the bed yeah on the 24th of may he gives a very he decides he's going to break the logjam. He gives this very, very rambling speech, wittering about everybody wants more participation in life. We'll set up councils, all this stuff.
chienlit。基本上就是狗在床上拉屎了，也就是把床弄脏了，是的，这显然不是——我的意思是，这是一个非常著名的评语，但它并没有起到让他赢得学生抗议者喜爱的作用，因为基本上，我想翻译的话，可以说他们是尿床鬼，他们把床尿湿了，是的。在 5 月 24 日，他发表了一个非常——他决定打破僵局。他发表了一场非常非常冗长、语无伦次的演讲，唠叨着每个人都想要更多地参与生活。我们将建立委员会，诸如此类。
This is no good at all. More protests, people shouting, Adieu de Gaulle in the streets. Now, actually, at this point, he's also got into difficulties because Daniel Kohn-Bendit, Danny the Red, the student radical who's become the face of the sort of the left wing of the student protests. He has been on a speaking tour, you know,
这根本毫无用处。更多的抗议，人们在街上大喊“打倒戴高乐”。现在，实际上，在这个时候，他也陷入了困境，因为丹尼尔·科恩-本迪特（Daniel Kohn-Bendit），“红色的丹尼”，这个学生激进分子，已经成了学生抗议左翼形象的代表。他一直在进行演讲巡回演出，你知道的，
there's that one of those very late 60s speaking tours where he's probably pitching up on panel shows with Mick Jagger and Mary Whitehouse or something. Yeah, editor of the Times. Exactly, exactly. And the French, now you were saying last time he's actually technically a german citizen yeah and he's jewish right so the spectacle of jews being deported from france by the french police is an incredible you know incendiary That is a very raw wound, isn't it? So the government bans him from returning to France.
就是那种非常 60 年代末风格的演讲巡回演出，他可能会出现在米克·贾格尔和玛丽·怀特豪斯之类的专题讨论节目中。是的，泰晤士报主编。没错，没错。而法国人，现在你上次说过他实际上在技术上是一个德国公民，是的，他是个犹太人，对吧。所以法国警察将犹太人驱逐出境的场面是一个令人难以置信的、具有煽动性的景象。那是一个非常未愈合的伤口，不是吗？所以政府禁止他返回法国。
This inflames the students. So you have yet more violence. The violence is now spreading to the right bank of the River Seine, by the way. Has anyone died? Yes. So two people die in total, I think it's fair to say. One guy is killed by a fragment of a grenade. And the other person, I can't actually remember how he died.
这激怒了学生。于是你们迎来了更多的暴力。顺便说一句，暴力现在已经蔓延到了塞纳河右岸。有人死吗？是的。总共有两个人死亡，我觉得这样说很公道。一个人被一颗手榴弹的碎片炸死了。另一个人，我其实记不清他是怎么死的了。
I think he's run over by a van or something. But actually, you know what, Tom? I mean, compared to the commune, Paris Commune. Compared with the Paris Commune. Compared with the repression of the Prague Spring later in the year. Compared with the riots in the US. So the riots that summer that greet the news of the assassination of Martin Luther King, where scores of people die.
我想他是被一辆货车什么的给撞了。但实际上，你知道吗，汤姆？我的意思是，与公社、巴黎公社相比。与巴黎公社相比。与当年晚些时候对布拉格之春的镇压相比。与美国的暴乱相比。所以那个夏天迎来马丁·路德·金遇刺消息的暴乱中，有数十人死亡。
I mean, the death toll, the CRS are cracking people's heads, but actually they don't really. So to that degree, they're not behaving like the SS. No, they're not like the SS. I mean, there's an irony here, isn't there? We talked in the last episode about the memory of the Parisian police killing Algerian demonstrators in 1961. You know, that's barely remembered.
我的意思是，死亡人数，防暴警察（CRS）在打破人们的头，但实际上他们并没有真的……所以在某种程度上，他们表现得不像党卫军。不，他们不像党卫军。我的意思是，这里有一个讽刺，不是吗？我们在上一集里讨论过巴黎警察在 1961 年杀害阿尔及利亚示威者的记忆。你知道，那几乎不被人记起。
It's mentioned in that film Caché that we were talking about. But the events of May 1968 in which effectively... Well, Caché is made by an Austrian director, Hanneke. But it's May 1968. It's the theatre, it's the spectacle of the student occupations that lingers in the memory. But, of course, at this this point if you're a french politician or a police chief you don't know that this is gonna that it's that
我们在讨论的那部电影《隐藏摄影机》（Caché）中提到了这一点。但 1968 年 5 月的事件，在其中实际上……好吧，《隐藏摄影机》是由奥地利导演哈内克制作的。但那是 1968 年 5 月。那是戏剧，学生占领的奇观在记忆中挥之不去。但是，当然，在这个时候，如果你是一个法国政治家或警察局长，你并不知道这会是——这纯粹是一场奇观，考虑到法国的历史，你会认为这真的在失控——我的意思是，这将成为巴黎公社。所以正是在这个时候，军队在制定应急计划以重新占领首都，这正是公社发生的事情，公社，是的，血腥的——我的意思是，如果真的发生了那种事，你可以想象死亡人数会有多高。他们正在计划，在城市外部集结军队以重新夺回首都。现在与此同时，他们正在奉行不同的路线。所以与此同时，政府说，好吧，让我们同工会谈谈，让工人们回去工作。现在我们上次提到了这一点，他们有所谓的
it's pure spectacle and you think given france's history this is really running out of control i mean this is going to be the paris commune so it's at this point that the army are making contingency plans to reoccupy the to reoccupy the capital which is what happened with the commune the commune yeah the bloody i mean if that had happened of course you can only imagine what the death toll would be they are planning they're readying troops outside the city to retake the capital now at the same time they're pursuing different tracks so at the same time the government said okay let's talk to the unions let's get the workers back to work now we mentioned this last time they have what's called
格勒内勒协议（Grenelle Accords），那是在 5 月 25 日和 26 日，其中一位谈判代表实际上是《历史的 restis》的朋友，色鬼、雅克·希拉克，是的。他是“六分钟先生”吗？好吧，有不同的说法，对吧？所以他要么是 3、4、5 或 6 分钟先生，连淋浴在内，这是指他与女性朋友的交往。没错。好吧，这完全扯远了。
the Grinnell Accords which is in the 25th and 26th of May one of the negotiators actually is a friend of the rest of history louche lounge lizard Jacques Chirac yes was he monsieur six minutes well there's different claims right so he's either Mr. 3, 4, 5, or 6 minutes, shower included, which is a reference to his interactions with his lady friends. Exactly. Okay, that's a complete tangent.
希拉克和他的同僚们。他们与工会达成了一项协议。我们上次提到了这一点。他们将获得最低工资的提高。他们将获得所有这些诸如此类的福利。CGT（法国总工会）的负责人，那个大型共产主义工会，乔治·塞基（Georges Segui），
Chirac and Co. They negotiate a deal with the unions. We mentioned this last time. They'll get an increase in the minimum wage. They'll get all these sort of goodies. The head of the CGT, the big communist union, Georges Segui,
他去到比扬古（Bilanco）的雷诺工厂，说，太棒的消息。我谈成了一笔棒极了的交易。人们说，不，还不够好。你知道，在那一刻，
he goes to Bilanco, to the Renault plant, and says, brilliant news. I've negotiated this fantastic deal. And people say, no, not good enough. You know, at that point,
情绪已经变得——这就是抗议的陶醉感。因其自身的可能性而陶醉。我认为这实际上是一个很好的表达方式。我的意思是，对陶醉的提及可能会听起来我们在表现得——你知道，不公平、过于批评。但我认为，对于任何抗议、任何革命，总有一种感觉，即这些事情获得了一种没有人能完全解释的动量。
the mood has become, it's this, the intoxication of protest. Drunk with the sense of its own possibility. I think that's a very good way of putting it, actually. I mean, the references to intoxication may sound that we're being, you know, unfair, too critical. But I think there is always a sense with any protest, with any revolution, that these things acquire a momentum that nobody can quite explain.
没有人知道发生了什么。而且非常好玩。而且非常好玩，正是如此。我的意思是，这是其中的关键部分。好吧，我们现在在 5 月，对吧？我的意思是，这是一个美丽的日子。这是一个可爱的地方。你绝对可以看出人们玩得非常开心。
Nobody knows what's going on. And great fun. And great fun, exactly so. I mean, that is a key part of it. Well, we're here in May, right? I mean, it's a beautiful day. It's a lovely place. You can absolutely see that people are having a tremendous
他们在占领建筑物。他们穿着高领毛衣。他们在讨论晦涩的哲学家。还有什么比这更好玩的？他们在要求不可能的事。是的。现在政府面对这一切以及对工会提议的拒绝，基本上已经黔驴技穷了。在 5 月底的这个时候，有一种感觉，你知道，没有人知道发生了什么，没有人知道它将如何解决，而且戴高乐已经黔驴技穷了，
time. They're occupying buildings. They're wearing polo necks. They're talking about obscure philosophers. What could be more fun? They are demanding the impossible yeah now the government faced with this and the rejection of its offer to the unions has basically run out of options there is a sort of sense at this point at the end of may that you know nobody knows what's going on nobody knows how it'll be resolved and that de gaulle has shot his bolt
他是个老头子了。他完全无关紧要了。弗朗索瓦·密特朗（François Mitterrand），他在 1965 年的上一届总统选举中输给了戴高乐，他说，国家已经不复存在了。你知道，国家已经失败了。我准备好掌权了。他在左翼的竞争对手皮埃尔·孟戴斯-弗朗斯（Gaico Pierre Mendez France）说，我也准备好掌权了，我会和共产党人合作。而共产党人此时此前一直置身事外，现在他们说，对，让我们组织一场
that he is an old man. He is completely irrelevant. François Mitterrand, who had lost the last presidential election to de Gaulle in 1965, he says, there is no more state. You know, the state has failed. I am ready to assume power. His rival on the left, Gaico Pierre Mendez France, he says, I'm also ready to assume power and I'll work with the communists. And the communists at this point, having previously stayed out of it, they now say, right, let's organize a
大规模的示威游行。所以他们是在赶时髦。是的。我的意思是，我知道当我这么说时你很吃惊，共产党人从来都不是这一切的粉丝。他们一直认为这是资产阶级的无稽之谈，但现在他们认为政府已经崩溃了。政府已经失败了。第五共和国已经死了。我们需要把自己置于接下来发生之事的 pole position（杆位）。所以他们计划在 5 月 29 日举行这场大型示威活动。现在，在 5 月 28 日的夜晚，
massive demonstration. So they're jumping on the bandwagon. Yeah. I mean, I know you were surprised when I said this, the communists have never been a fan of all this business. They had always thought this is bourgeois nonsense, but right now they think the government has collapsed. The government has failed. The Fifth Republic is dead. We need to put ourselves in pole position for what comes next. So they plan this big demonstration for the 29th of May. Now, on the night of the 28th of May,
戴高乐在爱丽舍宫。他已经完全失去了对事态的控制。他处于他的传记作者所说的……而爱丽舍宫距离我们现在坐的地方不远。不，我们可以……好吧，我们待会儿打个车过去，但我们完全可以走过去。我的意思是，暴力已经蔓延到了河的右岸。所以它离爱丽舍宫越来越近。人们冲进爱丽舍宫的前景看起来非常真实。我的意思是，在法国历史上这曾经发生过。好吧，凡尔赛宫的阴影、攻占巴士底狱的阴影——我的意思是，这些是法国历史上的经典事件。而戴高乐对法国历史有着深刻的感知，正如我们所提到的。所以那天晚上，他的传记作者朱利安·杰克逊（Julian Jackson）说，他在一种——我引述一下——“世界末日般的绝望”状态中度过了这一夜。
de Gaulle is at the Elysee Palace. He has completely lost control of events. He is in what his biography... And the Elysee Palace is not far from where we're sitting now. No, we could... Well, we'll get a taxi to it later, but we could walk. I mean, the violence has already spread onto the right bank of the river. So it is coming closer and closer to the Elysee. The prospect of people storming the Elysee seems very real. I mean, it's happened before in French history. Well, so the shadow of Versailles, of the storming of the Bastille, I mean, these are
他做出了三个——好吧，几个有趣的的历史比较。首先，顺便说一句，他的妻子伊冯（Yvonne）泪流满面。她认为他们会被私刑处死。他们会被送上断头台。谁知道会发生什么？顺便说一句，他对妻子说的是，伊冯，泪流满面。她认为他们会被私刑处死。他们会被送上断头台。谁知道会发生什么？他对他的助手们说，这就像 1940 年。
the canonical events in French history. And de Gaulle has a profound sense of French history, as we've mentioned. So that night, his biographer, Julian Jackson, says he spends the night in a state of, and I quote, apocalyptic despair.
我记得 1940 年。这是一个抉择的时刻。但随后他对他的助手们说，我已经没有精力来处理这些了。我是一个老头子了。我不再是个年轻人了。他向助手们说的第二件事是，这一切的根源深植于法国，所以我们作为一个国家，从来没有从被英国人在滑铁卢击败以及被普鲁士人在色当击败中恢复过来，你知道，这是深层的，这是深奥的东西，汤姆。然后他的助手对他说，你
He makes three, well, several interesting historical comparisons. First of all, his wife is, by the way, Yvonne, is in floods of tears. She thinks they're going to be lynched. They're going to be guillotined. Who knows what's going to happen? He says to his wife is, by the way, Yvonne, is in floods of tears. She thinks they're going to be lynched. They're going to be guillotined. Who knows what's going to happen? He says to his aides, this is like 1940.
我们应该逃往凡尔赛，你知道，去凡尔赛，离开这个城市。他说，我不是路易·菲利普——我们谈到过的那个人。那个梨。看起来像个梨。法国最后一个梨形国王。我们在克里斯·克拉克（Chris Clark）那集的 1848 年节目中谈到过他。他逃跑了。戴高乐说，我不会逃跑。
I remember 1940. This is a moment of decision. But he then says to his aides, I don't have the energy anymore to deal with this. I'm an old man. I'm not a young man anymore. The second thing he says to his aides, says the roots of this are deep in france so we as a nation have never recovered from being beaten at waterloo by the english and at sedon by the prussians you know this is deep this is deep stuff tom and then his aides say to him you
所以他整夜未眠，5 月 29 日。这一天，共产党人和大型共产主义工会 CGT 正准备举行大游行。警察预计有 5 万人，共产党人声称那里有大约 40 万人，他们游行穿过巴黎，高喊“打倒戴高乐，再见戴高乐，告别戴高乐”。有趣的是，这是历史上的一个真正转折点。他们试图占领关键建筑吗？共产党人？共产党人，是的。警察已经为此做好了准备。可能会发生枪击事件。
we should flee to versailles you know go to versailles get out the city and he says i am not louis philippe who we talked about. The pear. It looked like a pear. The pear-shaped last king of France. We talked about him in our 1848 episode with Chris Clark. He ran away. De Gaulle says, I'm not going to run away.
可能会发生大规模的街头暴力。在那一点上，会有大量的流血事件，甚至整个事情可能会彻底失控。
So he lies awake all night, 29th of May. This is the day that the communists and the big communist union, the CGT, are prepared for a big march um the police are expecting 50 000 the communists claim there are about 400 000 people there marching through paris chanting adieu de gaulle goodbye de gaulle farewell de gaulle it's interesting this is a real turning point in history have they tried to occupy key buildings the communists the communists yeah the police are prepared for that. There probably would have been shooting.
好吧。所以这是一个巨大的“如果”。这是一个巨大的“如果”。与此同时，戴高乐本应在 29 日上午会见他的部长们。他推迟了这次会面。
There probably would have been massive street violence. At that point, there would have been a lot of bloodshed and possibly the whole thing could have spiraled massively out of control.
他说不开会了。他开始收拾他所有的个人文件，把它们全部准备好从爱丽舍宫搬走。他对他的女婿——一个叫阿兰·德·布瓦济约（Alain de Boisieu）的人说，我不想给抗议者攻击爱丽舍宫的机会。如果为了我个人的防卫而流血，那将是令人遗憾的。我决定离开，因为没有人会去攻击一座空宫殿。他对他的助手们说，我崩溃了。我要离开首都。我要去科隆布代莱德格尔，就是你谈到的那个地方。
Okay. So that's a huge what if. It's a huge what if. Meanwhile, de Gaulle, he was meant to be meeting his ministers on the morning of the 29th. He postpones the meeting.
是的，他的乡村隐秘处。是的。他是法兰西的灵魂。我要去我的乡村别墅与法兰西的灵魂进行心灵交流。与此同时，他其实留了一手。他让一位将军来找他，并对他说，去巴登-巴登，去西德境内的法国军队那里，越过边界，对吧？所以这就像莱茵河畔的英国军队、驻德美军一样。法国在 1945 年的德国也被分派了一部分西德来进行行政管理——我的意思是，当时的德国正如 1945 年那样，确切地说，法国军队仍然在那里驻扎。所以西德边界那边有法国军队。
He says no meeting. He starts to take all his personal papers, get them all ready to remove them from the Elysee Palace. He says to his son-in-law, who is a man called Alain de Boisieu, he says, I don't want to give the protesters a chance to attack the Elysee. It would be regrettable if blood was shed in my personal defense. I've decided to leave because nobody attacks an empty palace. And he says to his aides, I'm shattered. I'm leaving the capital. I'm going to Colombe, Les Desanglies, which you talked about.
他说，我想让你去跟指挥法国军队的那个人谈谈。他是一个名叫马叙将军（General Massou）的人。现在，马叙将军曾在第二次世界大战中加入自由法国。他在印度支那服过役。他在 1956 年的苏伊士运河服过役。他是一名伞兵指挥官。最著名的是——我的意思是，去过我们在莱斯特广场的展映活动的观众们，汤姆，当我们谈到我们最喜欢的历史电影时，那些受到启发去观看《阿尔及尔之战》（The Battle of Algiers）的人会记得马修上校，
Yeah, his country hideaway. Yeah. He's the soul of France. I'm going to commune with the soul of France at my country house. Meanwhile, he's actually got something up up his sleeve he gets a general to come to him and he says go to baden-baden to the french forces in baden-baden over the border in west germany right so this is like the british army on the rhine the u.s forces in germany france also has been given a portion of west germany to administer in the i mean germany as it was in 1945 exactly and exactly French troops are still in situ there. So there are French troops over the border in West Germany.
我想他叫这个名字，那个伞兵指挥官。非常有个人魅力。《阿尔及尔之战》里的那个。好吧，他的原型就是雅克·马叙。马叙曾在阿尔及利亚问题上与戴高乐产生过裂痕。他说戴高乐出卖了阿尔及利亚。但在个人层面上，他仍然忠于戴高乐。他们有着共同的解放经历。因为 1940 年。源自 1940 年。基本上，戴高乐现在派了这个人，阿兰将军，
And he says, I want you to talk to the guy who's in command of the French troops. He's a man called General Massou. Now, General Massou had been part of the Free French in the Second World War. He'd served in Indochina. He'd served at Suez in 1956. He was a paratrooper commander. Most famously, I mean, people who went to our show, Tom, at the Leicester Square, when we talked about our favorite historical films, those people who were inspired by that to watch the Battle of Algiers will remember Colonel Mathieu,
去对马叙说，我们能指望你吗？我们需要你。我们需要德国的军队。你基本上得向首都进军。一切都失控了。与此同时，戴高乐仍然在爱丽舍宫。他与他的总理乔治·蓬皮杜（Georges Pompidou）开会。实际上，戴高乐和蓬皮杜之间存在着大量的紧张关系。
I think he's called, the paratrooper commander. Very charismatic. In the Battle of Algiers. Well, he is inspired by Jacques Massou. Massou had a breach with de Gaulle over Algeria. He said that de Gaulle had sold out Algeria. But on a personal level, he remains loyal to de Gaulle. They have a shared experience of the liberation. Because of 1940. Out of 1940. And basically, de Gaulle now has sent this guy, General Allende,
蓬皮杜，这有点像安东尼·艾登和温斯顿·丘吉尔之间的那种紧张关系，或者像国王和王太子之间。国王和王太子。蓬皮杜基本上认为戴高乐已经是一个失败的政客，希望他离开——是的，呃——而戴高乐对蓬皮杜非常生气，认为他总是在某种程度上破坏自己之类的事情。戴高乐把他的总理蓬皮杜叫进来，对他说，我老了，你还年轻，你是未来，再见，拥抱你（au revoir je vous embrasse）。非常奇怪，你知道，蓬皮杜心里想，这到底是怎么回事？然后戴高乐和他的妻子乘直升机起飞了，他们要去科隆布的乡村别墅，但刚一起飞，他就告诉了飞行员一件他没有告诉蓬皮杜或任何其他人的事情：好吧，我们不去科隆布，我们实际上要去
to say to Massou, can we rely on you? We need you. We need the troops in Germany. You're going to have to basically march on the capital. Everything's gone out of control. Meanwhile, de Gaulle is still at the Elysee. He has a meeting with Georges Pompidou, his prime minister. There's actually loads of tension between de Gaulle and Pompidou.
巴登-巴登，我们要去德国。回到巴黎，蓬皮杜和他的同僚们发现戴高乐根本没有去他的乡村别墅，他没有去科隆布。他们当时就想，什么？怎么回事？蓬皮杜陷入了彻底的——所有人都陷入了彻底的恐慌。好吧，你也会这样的，不是吗？将军逃跑了。将军消失了。
Pompidou, it's a bit like the tension between Anthony Eden and Winston Churchill or something. Yeah, or between the king and the Dauphin. The king and the Dauphin. Pompidou basically thinks de Gaulle is a busted flush, wants him to leave on yeah uh to go is very cross with pompadour and thinks he's always sort of undermining him and stuff to go calls in pompadour his prime minister and he says to him i'm old you are young you are the future au revoir je vous embrasse very strange you know pompadour thinks what's going on here then toulle takes off by helicopter with his wife they're going to Colombay to his country house but as soon as they've taken off he tells the pilot something he hasn't told Pompidou or anybody else okay we're not going to Colombia we're actually going
你知道，我们找不到他在哪里。人们到处跑着喊，他逃出国了。一切都结束了。蓬皮杜的一个朋友带着一把枪走进来交给蓬皮杜说，你知道，你会需要这个的。有人在烧文件。有人在
to Baden-Baden we're going to Germany back in Paris Pompidou and co discover that de Gaulle is not going to his country house after all that he he's not going to Colombay. And they're like, what? What's going on? Pompidou is in a complete, everybody's in a complete funk. Well, you would be, wouldn't you? The general has fled. The general has vanished.
计划离开这座城市的行程，说，我们怎么离开？加油站因为罢工而关闭了。你知道，
You know, we can't find where he is. People are running around shouting, he's fled the country. It's all over. One of Pompidou's friends comes in with a gun for Pompidou and says, you know, you're going to need this. There are people burning documents. There are people
我们得去弄汽油。当革命者冲进宫殿时会发生什么？你知道，所有这些类似的事情。人们试图
planning their journey out of the city saying, how do we get out? The petrol stations are closed because of the strikes. You know,
弄到假的身份证。这就像我们制作的关于……呃……西贡沦陷的那集一样，绝对是，这非常像美国大使馆。最终，消息传到了蓬皮杜这里，我们知道戴高乐去哪里了。他去了德国，他去了巴登-巴登。戴高乐的直升机于下午 2 点 40 分降落在巴登-巴登的军用机场。与此同时，当然，共产党人在下午三点钟正在城里游行。马叙此前对此完全没有得到任何预警，他去见戴高乐，而戴高乐一开始的对话就是：结束了，完蛋了。
we're going to have to take petrol. What happens when the revolutionaries storm the palace? You know, all this sort of stuff. People are trying
一切都搞砸了。他开始疯狂抱怨，对马叙说，结束了，我失去了控制，我不知道发生了什么。而且我认为，马叙——当然还有戴高乐的传记作者朱利安·杰克逊说——你知道，是马叙对他说，给他打气，一切都会好起来的，没问题的，我向你保证军队会是忠诚的。因为这就是戴高乐离开的原因，是的，如果军队背叛了他，那就彻底完了。为了检验军队的忠诚度，回巴黎去。我们和你在一起。
to get fake ID cards. It's like the episode we did on um fall of saigon it's absolutely it's very american embassy eventually word comes to pompadour we know where de gaulle has gone he has gone to germany he's gone to baden-barbon de gaulle's helicopter lands at baden-barbon at the military airport at 2 40 p.m meanwhile of course the communists are marching through the city at three o'clock masu who's not been forewarned about this at all really he gets to you know see to go and to go starts the conversation by saying it's finished it's done
如果枪击开始，你可以依靠我们。所以戴高乐仍然有点优柔寡断。他想，嗯，我要在德国向全国发表讲话吗？我要在斯特拉斯堡向全国发表讲话吗？最终决定，不，我要回科隆布。他飞回了科隆布。有趣的是，戴高乐的一部分仍然心存最坏的打算，因为他的妻子伊冯把家族珠宝、戴高乐家族的珠宝交给了他的儿子和儿媳，
everything is screwed and he just goes on this massive rant and he says to masu it's finished i've lost control i don't know what's going on and i think at most you know certainly julian jackson de gaulle's biographer says you know it's masu who says to him who stiffens him it'll be all right it's going to be fine i promise you the troops will be loyal because that's why de gaulle is gone yeah if the army turns against him, it's lost. To test the loyalty of the army, go back to Paris. We are with you.
他们留在了巴登-巴登的军事基地。其目的是将其作为万一最坏情况发生时的逃生密室——如果最坏情况真的发生，他们将离开巴黎逃往德国，然后谁知道呢。无论如何，与此同时，戴高乐已经回到了科隆布，他随后将返回巴黎，并在第二天做出他决定性的介入，而且汤姆，绝不仅仅因为一大群游客聚集在咖啡馆周围，他们显然听说了——是的，呃——好莱坞的汤姆·霍兰在这里，或者也许他们正准备参与一些情境主义（Situationist）街头戏剧，所以我认为我们应该去看看
You can rely on us if the shooting starts. So de Gaulle's still dithering a bit. He thinks, well, will I address the nation from Germany? Will I address the nation from Strasbourg? Eventually decides, no, I will go back to Colombie. He flies back to Colombie. Now, interestingly, part of de Gaulle still fears the worst because his wife, Yvonne, has given the family jewels, the de Gaulle family jewels, to his son and his daughter-in-law,
将军，因为在河的另一边、爱丽舍宫旁边就有一尊戴高乐的雕像，我觉得我们应该乘出租车去那里，因为我知道你不太喜欢走路，而——是什么绝对让我下定决心我们应该这么做，那就是 WISE 的易用性，因为我们现在是用我们的数字卡付款的。如果你想订购一张实体卡，只需五分钟即可搞定。我已经办了。我试过了。我有一张。是的，我办了。所以无论如何，无论你是在商店里，无论你像我们现在这样在咖啡馆里，还是在线上，你总是能以最优惠的价格拥有合适种类的货币。
and they stay in Baden-Baden at the military base. So with the aim of keeping it as a bolt hole should the worst come to the worst should the worst come to the worst they're going to leave paris flee to germany and then who knows anyway in the meantime de gaulle has come back to colombia he is then going to go back to paris and the next day he is going to make his decisive intervention and tom i think not least because a huge mob of tourists have assembled surrounding the cafe they've obviously heard yeah that uh hollywood's tom holland is here or maybe they're about to to engage in some situationist street theater so i think we should go and see the
所以我们去叫辆出租车吧。等我们回来时，我们就在香榭丽舍大街了。我们走吧。好的，汤姆，我们刚坐上了出租车。我们刚才在左岸，离索邦大学不远。我们现在正在过河，穿过鲁桑（Roussaint），来到右岸。我们要去靠近爱丽舍宫和戴高乐将军雕像的地方。我要支付车费，当然，这让我们容易多了，汤姆，多亏了 WISE。现在我们用数字卡支付，但你只需五分钟就能订购一张实体卡。
general because there's a statue of de gaulle okay just by the elise palace on the other side of the river and i think we should uh take a camp to get there because i know you're not a great one for walking and uh what absolutely decides me that that's what we should do is the ease of use of WISE because we are now paying with our digital cards. And if you want to order a physical card, you can get that in just five minutes. I've done that. I've tried. I've got one. Yeah, I did. So either way, whether you are in a shop, whether you're in a cafe as we are now, whether you're online, you always have the right kind of money for the right price.
现在无论如何，无论是在实体店还是在线上，你总能以最优惠的价格拥有合适种类的货币。好，我们走吧。用一下应用程序。好了，先生（Voilà, monsieur）。太简单了。谢谢（Merci）。谢谢，先生（Merci, monsieur）。那么，多米尼克，我们已经穿过了塞纳河。
So let's go and get the cab. And when we come back, we will be on the Champs-Élysées. Allons-y. All right, Tom, we've just jumped into the cab. We were on the left bank, not far from the Sorbonne. We're now on our way across the river, across the Roussaint, onto the right bank. And we're going up to the near the Élys Palace, and the statue of General de Gaulle. And I'm going to pay for the cab journey, and of course that's made much easier for us, Tom, with WISE. Now we're paying with our digital cards, but you can order a physical card in just five minutes.
我们把左岸（Rive Gauche）抛在了身后。我们真正抵达了巴黎的宏伟大中心。远处的香榭丽舍大街。是的。所以我们在这里找到了一个安静的好地方，我们可以看到戴高乐雕像。我们刚才看过的，汤姆。所以他是一个身材修长、大步流星的人物。不得不说，跟你挺像的。
Now either way, whether you're in-store or online, you've always got the right kind of money for the right price. Right, here we go. Let's use the app. Voilà, monsieur. So easy. Merci. Merci, monsieur. So, Dominic, we have crossed the Seine.
命运之子。是的。所以那就是雕像。现在那边，显然，我不知道为什么我要指着它，因为观众或听众看不到它。但无论如何，为了完整起见，爱丽舍宫就在前方步行大约一分钟左右的地方，还有向远处延伸的香榭丽舍大街，伟大的戏剧即将那里上演，汤姆。所以——我们把时间停留在 5 月 29 日的晚上，对吧？回到科隆布，而 30 日的早晨他在爱丽舍宫醒来，他的助手们走进来，
We've left the Rive Gauche behind us. And we've arrived really in the great center of Paris. The Champs-Élysées in the distance. Yes. So we've got a nice quiet spot here, but we can just see the Statue de Gaulle. We were looking at earlier, Tom. So he's this sort of lanky, striding figure. Not unlike yourself, I have to say.
发现他判若两人。他已经抛弃了所有的优柔寡断、焦虑和不确定性，他看起来——基本上，对雅克·马叙和军队的那次拜访，一旦他知道他拥有军队，他就知道他不会遭遇路易·菲利普或路易十六世或其他人的命运。他们说，好吧，我们计划了一场大型的戴高乐主义者游行，这是一场针对昨天共产党人游行的反游行。太好了。他说，好吧，我将在晚上发表讲话。我决定向法国人民发表讲话。
Man of destiny. Yeah. So there's the statue. Now over there, obviously, I don't know why I'm pointing out because the viewers can't or the listeners can't see it. But anyway, for of completeness the elise palace is just a minute or so up there and there's the chance elise stretching into the distance and that's where the great drama is about to unfold tom so so we left it on the evening of the 29th of may didn't we to go back at columbia and the morning of the 30th finds him at the Elysee Palace and his aides come
然后这个叫福卡尔（Fokar）的人提出了一个非常好的建议。他说，不要在晚上发表讲话。在游行之前发表讲话，以便在某种程度上激发你的人民、你的法兰西。他会见的另一个人是节目之友乔治·蓬皮杜，他的总理，他说，我要你解散国民议会并进行选举，戴高乐说，太好了，我们就这么办。所以他们终于有了一些清晰的思路。第一件事是演讲，戴高乐在下午 4 点半发表了演讲。至关重要的是，他没有在电视上发表讲话。
in and they find him a man transformed he's lost all the sort of ditheriness and the the anxiety and the uncertainty and he seems you know basically that visit to Jacques Massieu and the army once he knows he's got the army he knows he's not going to suffer the fate of Louis Philippe or you know Louis the 16VI or whatever. And they say, well, we've got this big Gaullist demonstration planned, a counter demonstration in answer to the communist demonstration yesterday. Great. And he says, well, I'm going to give a speech in the evening. I've decided I'm going to speak to the French people.
所以他在广播中发表讲话，就像他在 1940 年从伦敦发表讲话时那样。所以人们没有——他们没有在电视上看到一个疲惫的老人。他们听到的是他们与抵抗运动和伴随着解放的广播联系在一起的声音，这是一个非常简短的演讲，只有四分钟。简短非常重要，因为在这个充斥着空洞口号（如“要求不可能的事”等等）的时期，戴高乐的讲话非常干练而精确。他说，回去工作吧，回大学去吧。我马上解决这个问题。我正在解散议会。我们将举行选举。选择非常明确。
And then this guy called Fokar has a very good suggestion. He says, don't do the speech in the evening. Do the speech before the demonstration to kind of fire up your people your france the other person he meets is george pompidou friend of the show who um his prime minister he says i want you to dissolve the national assembly and let's have elections and to call it's like great let's do it so finally they have some clarity so the first thing is the speech and de Gaulle gives the speech at 4.30 in the afternoon and crucially he doesn't speak on TV.
它介于一个作为极权主义企业的政党的恐吓、陶醉和暴政之间——指的是共产党人——或者是我。这就是选择。这有点像——这是一个愚蠢的比喻，但它有点像 2019 年的英国，你知道，有一种清晰度：你要么和我在一起，要么和他们在一起，自己做决定，你知道，这就是“搞定脱欧”（get brexit done），当然我们知道结果并不是把戴高乐将军比作这个的好配方，所以这是一个荒谬绝伦的比喻，但这就是我们在《历史的 restis》中的作用。无论如何，他说选择非常明确。要么是我，要么是他们。他还说，如果还有任何扰乱选举的抗议活动，
So he's speaking on radio as he had done in 1940 from London. So what people don't, they don't see a tired old man on television. They hear the voice they associate with broadcast from resistance and resistance with liberation and it's a very short speech it's only four minutes the brevity is important because it's at this time of vacuous slogans demande l'impossible and stuff de gaulle is really clipped and precise he says you know go back to work go back to universities. I'm going to settle this now. I'm dissolving parliament. We will have elections. The choice is very clear.
我将毫不犹豫地动用宪法第 16 条赋予我的紧急权力，基本上宣布进入紧急状态并进行某种形式的统治。所以有一种非常强烈的“这就是决定性时刻”的感觉。将军在某种程度上——你知道，挺身而出，履行他在剧中的角色，就像他在 1940 年所做的那样。对于他的支持者来说，这绝对是他们几个星期以来一直渴望看到的戴高乐，我想这么说。我的意思是，朱利安·杰克逊在他的传记中说，这不仅仅是戴高乐单枪匹马扭转乾坤。潮流已经开始转变，因为抗议活动虽然很好玩，但有些人确实想要汽油；巴黎的店主们厌倦了窗户被砸碎，其实只想恢复正常的商业运营，诸如此类。但戴高乐的演讲产生了不可思议的影响……这是历史上的一个例子，一场演讲产生了真正的激发效应，因为他们原本预计——你知道，香榭丽舍大街上有 30 万人。历史学家对具体人数存在分歧，但我想许多人会同意，这可能是巴黎历史上那一刻单场规模最大的游行。也许有 80 万人，也许有 50 万人。很难确切知道。但他们是一群庞大的人群。他们是尼克松的沉默大多数，汤姆。而且他们普遍年纪较大吗？
It is between the intimidation, intoxication, and tyranny of a party that is a totalitarian enterprise, meaning the communists, or it is me. That is the choice. It's a bit kind of, it's a stupid comparison, but it's a a bit britain in 2019 you know there's a sort of a clarity you're with me or you're with them decide you know it's the get brexit done which of course we know didn't turn out to be a recipe for comparing general gold which is bad so it was a ridiculous ridiculous comparison but that's what we're for on the rest of this history anyway he says the choice is very clear. It's me or them. He also says, if there's any more protests that disrupt the elections,
他们并不全都是年长者。那里有年轻人。因为别忘了，有很多人——你知道吗？我在学校的法国老师勒内·菲洛（René Filot）就是一个法属阿尔及利亚白人（Pied-Noir）。
I will not hesitate to use my emergency powers in the Constitution under Article 16 to basically declare a state of emergency and rule as it were by decree. So there's a real sense of like, this is the moment of decisiveness. The general has kind of, you know, stepped up to fulfill his part in the drama as he did in 1940. And for his supporters, this is absolutely the De Gaulle they've been itching to see for weeks, I would say. I mean, Julian Jackson in his biography says it's not just about De Gaulle turning the tide single-handedly. The tide was already beginning to turn because the protests were great fun, but there are people who actually do want petrol. And the shopkeepers in Paris who are sick of having their windows smashed in
我将毫不犹豫地动用宪法第16条赋予我的紧急权力，基本上宣布进入紧急状态，并依此进行统治。因此，有一种真正的主观感受，即：这是决定性的时刻。这位将军可以说是挺身而出，履行了他在1940年戏剧中所扮演的角色，就像当年一样。对他的支持者来说，这绝对是他们几个星期以来一直渴望看到的戴高乐。我的意思是，朱利安·杰克逊在他的传记中说，这不仅仅是戴高乐单枪匹马力挽狂澜。大势其实已经开始转变，因为抗议活动虽然很有趣，但确实有人需要汽油。巴黎的店主们也厌倦了他们的橱窗被砸碎
and actually would just like to get back to business as usual and all of this stuff. But De Gaulle's speech has an incredible... It's one of those instances in history of a speech having a genuine galvanizing effect, because they're expecting, you know, 300,000 people on the streets, on the Champs-Élysées. Historians disagree about how many there were, but I think many would agree this is probably the single biggest demonstration at that point in Parisian history. Maybe 800,000 people, maybe half a million people. It's hard to know. But they're a huge crowd. They're Nixon's silent majority, Tom. And are they generally older?
实际上，他们只想恢复往常的生和一切。但戴高乐的演讲具有难以置信的……这是历史上的那些时刻之一，演讲产生了真正的激励效果，因为他们原本预计，你知道的，街头和香榭丽舍大街上会有30万人。历史学家对具体人数存在分歧，但我认为很多人会同意，这可能是巴黎历史上当时规模最大的一次游行示威。也许有80万人，也许有50万人。很难确切知道。但他们是一群庞大的人群。他们是尼克松的沉默的大多数，汤姆。他们普遍年纪比较大吗？
They're not all older. There are young people there. Because don't forget, there are a lot of... I mean, do you know what? My French teacher at school, René Filot, he was a Pied-Noir.
并非全都是年纪较大的人。现场也有年轻人。因为别忘了，有很多……我的意思是，你知道吗？我学校的法语老师勒内·菲洛特，他是一名黑脚（阿尔及利亚法裔）。
His family were Pied-Noirs who'd come from Algeria. Yeah. He was very cool. He wore a polo neck. He changed smokes. So why is he not on the side of the Orage i think
他的家人是来自阿尔及利亚的黑脚法国人。是的。他很酷。他穿着高领毛衣。他换了烟。那么他为什么不在奥拉日这一边呢，我想
because he loved i tell you who he loved used to say shirak simonom oh you know sirak is my man kind of he loved shirak he despised the uh the radicals of 68 and i think there are an awful lot of people like that there are a lot of conservative students so people are listening on their little radios as de gaulle is speaking. They've gathered in the Place de la Concorde, and they are absolutely, I mean, people describe it as electrifying. You know, they are... Cross of Lorraine, all that kind of thing. The hero of France's past has re-emerged.
因为他爱，我告诉你他爱谁，他曾经说希拉克，西蒙，哦你知道希拉克是我的菜，某种程度上他爱希拉克，他鄙视那些激进派，而且我认为有相当多这样的人，有很多保守派学生，所以当戴高乐在发言时，人们正用他们的小收音机听着。他们聚集在协和广场，他们绝对——我的意思是，人们将其形容为电光石火般震撼。你知道，他们是……洛林十字勋章，诸如此类的事情。法国过去的英雄又重新出现了。
And, of course, the other thing, they march down the Champs-Élysées, they fill the Champs-Élysées just a few steps from where we are now. And the point about that is, again, it's the liberation. That's the street down which de Gaulle marched in 1940, and the point about that is again it's the liberation that's the street down which the goal marched in 1940 with and the crowds so so actually i mean the weird thing is you you accused uh well accused i mean you said described um the the students as in a way playing a part from a part in a drama yeah and in a sense the goal is reprising a drama in which he was the star yeah kind of retracing his steps isn't that what politicians do there tom you know yourself from your books on rome of course that's what
当然，还有一件事，他们沿着香榭丽舍大街游行，他们填满了香榭丽舍大街，距离我们现在所在地只有几步之遥。关键在于，这同样是解放。那是戴高乐在1940年游行通过的街道，关键在于，这同样是解放，那是戴高乐在1940年游行通过的街道，伴随着人群——所以实际上，我的意思是奇怪的是，你指责了——嗯，指责，我的意思是，你把学生们描述为在某种程度上在戏剧中扮演一个角色，是的，从某种意义上说，戴高乐正在重演一幕他曾是主角的戏剧，是的，某种程度上在重溯他的足迹，政治家不就是这样吗，汤姆？你自己从你关于罗马的书里就知道，当然就是这样
yeah augustus but he's he's using the set of triumphs past yeah but it is literal street theater it is it is exactly it is it's genius and, it's so often the way with these sort of, these growing bubbles of kind of revolutionary enthusiasm. It just takes one prick. And suddenly... Which prick is it? Yeah, I was regretting that metaphor as soon as I embarked upon it. I knew you'd enjoy that. The whole mood changes.
是的，奥古стус（奥古斯都），但他用的是过去凯旋的布景，是的，但这就是字面意义上的街头剧场，它确实是，它是天才之举，而且这种由某种不断增长的革命热情形成的泡沫，往往就是这样。只需要一根刺。突然……到底是哪根刺？是的，我一说出那个隐喻就开始后悔了。我知道你会喜欢这个。整个氛围都变了。
I think basically it's a shock for a lot of the students and for the radicals. As is so often the way when all these other people pitch up waving french flags and saying hurrah for the president hurrah for the general they're like what where did all these people come from yeah you know they've crawled out from under their rocks and the other key thing actually which is always so always underestimated in all accounts of revolutions riots and such it's a holiday a holiday is coming it's going to be the whitson holiday weekend and lots of people are going to go to the beach or to
我认为基本上这对许多学生和激进分子来说是个打击。正如当所有这些其他挥舞着法国国旗并高喊“总统万岁”、“将军万岁”的人涌现时经常发生的那样，他们会想：什么，这些人都是从哪儿冒出来的？是的，你知道的，他们从各自的石头缝里爬出来了。另一个关键点其实是，在所有关于革命、骚乱及类似事件的叙述中，这一点总是被严重低估：这是一个假期，一个假期即将到来，这将是圣灵降临节的长周末，许多人打算去海滩或者去
their country houses because it's the beginning of june and actually what happens i i my my extremely mean-spirited thought is that a lot of people hear from their parents that they're going to the holiday they're going to the holiday home. They're like, oh, right, well, that goes. We'll put the revolution on hold. Oh, put the revolution, exactly. And then when they come back, so there's one more night of the barricades on the 10th and 11th of June,
他们的乡间别墅，因为那是六月初。实际上发生的事情是——我这个极其刻薄的想法是——很多人听到父母说要去度假，要去度假屋。他们会想，哦，对吧，那就这样吧。我们把革命搁置一下。哦，把革命搁置，没错。然后当他们回来时，所以在6月10日和11日还有最后一晚的路障，
but that's really a bit of a last spasm, I would say. The Sorbonne is cleared by the 13th of June. The next day, a lot of students had occupied the Odeon Theatre and they had said, this is going to be a kind of National Assembly type thing. the police clear that as well. And so what happens in the election when is that? Well so the election de Gaulle frames it brilliantly he says it's me or the communists and the communists ironically who had not been keen on the whole thing yeah he says that is the choice you're on the forces of order against communism. And what about Mitterrand and
但我得说，那真的只是一阵最后的痉挛。索邦大学在6月13日之前就被清空了。第二天，许多学生占领了奥德昂剧院，他们说，这将是一个类似于国民议会的机构。警察也将其清除了。那么选举是什么时候发生的呢？嗯，所以戴高乐极其巧妙地策划了这场选举，他说：要么选我，要么选共产党。而讽刺的是，那些原本对整件事并不热心的共产党人，是的，他说这就是选择，你是站在秩序力量一边还是共产主义一边。那么密特朗和
Mendes France who had both kind of tried to put themselves at the head? They both lose their seats ironically. So it's the biggest at that point the biggest legislative landslide
孟德斯·法国（皮埃尔·孟代斯·弗朗斯），他们都曾试图将自己推到领导地位？讽刺的是，他们都失去了议席。所以这是当时最大的一次立法选举压倒性胜利
in French history. So in the first round 486 seats de Gaulle's party win 353 the communists win 34 and the socialists
在法国历史上。所以在第一轮投票中，486个席位里，戴高乐的政党赢得了353个，共产党赢得34个，社会党
win 57. So for the left it is an absolute disaster and actually anticipates what's going to happen in america where nixon wins the presidential election so um 1968 is the year the beatles release revolution and famously they record two versions of it yeah the first of which you know count me in for revolution yeah and then they do one count me out. Right. And in a sense, they are speaking for France.
赢得57个。所以对左翼来说，这是一场绝对的灾难，并且实际上预示了即将在美国发生的事情——尼克松赢得了总统大选——所以，1968年是披头士乐队发行《革命》这一单曲的年份，众所周知他们录制了两个版本，是的，其中第一个版本，你知道的，“算我一个参加革命吧”，然后他们做了一个是“把我排除在外”。没错。从某种意义上说，他们在为法国发声。
So, first of all, count me in. Yeah. And then suddenly they change their mind and think count me out. Well, the funny thing is people did opinion polls
所以，首先，算我一个。是的。然后他们突然改变主意，觉得把我排除在外。嗯，有趣的是，人们做了民意调查，
and they found that 20% of the French public said they'd like a revolution. I think that's true of all moments in French history. That the fifth of the French public
他们发现20%的法国公众表示他们想要一场革命。我认为法国历史上的所有时期都是如此。五分之一的法国公众
would like a revolution. Yeah. About the same proportion would have said, you know, I'd take to the streets to oppose it. And the rest, like, you know, don't care, would stay out. And these are the Sandbrook masses.
想要一场革命。是的。差不多同样比例的人会说，“你知道的，我会走上街头去反对它。”而其余的人，就像，“你知道的，不在乎”，会置身事外。这些就是桑德布鲁克大众。
The Sandbrook masses. The subjects of your books. Yeah. They're thinking about the sound of music. Yeah. Whatever the French equivalent of Bernie-ins are. Absolutely. Yeah.
桑德布鲁克大众。你书中的主角。是的。他们在想着音乐之声。是的。不管法国版本的伯尼支持者是什么。绝对是的。
So from a purely political perspective, I would say, and it won't surprise you or anybody else to hear me say this, that to my mind, the événements of May 1968 are a cul-de-sac. They're a failure. The result is, I mean,
所以从纯粹的政治角度来看，我要说——听到我这么说，你或其他任何人都不会感到惊讶——在我看来，1968年5月的事件是一个死胡同。它们是一场失败。结果是，我的意思是，
de Gaulle does step down a year later, but he's tired. He was probably going to do that anyway. I don't think that's George Pompidou who takes over.
戴高乐确实在一年后辞职了，但他累了。他无论如何都可能会这么做。我不认为那是乔治·蓬皮杜接任的原因。
Yeah. But I mean, after that, what happens? It's not like the left are kind of, you know waiting in the wings so mitan does become president in the 1980s but even metronome i
是的。但我的意思是，在那之后，发生了什么？并不是说左翼一直在幕后等待，所以密特朗确实在20世纪80年代成了总统，但即使是密特朗，
would argue ultimately turns out to be a much more conservative figure than many people anticipated by and large i would say politically what happens with france is that sort of english or rather british left of center people tend to idealize France and to imagine that it's this kind of social democratic paradise. But actually I would say France is in many ways a remarkably conservative country. I mean, just to give the example of the CRS, the CRS is still out there bashing people over the head at the slightest sign of protest. Yes, but you could advance an argument that the impact of May 68 is actually i mean it may sound a bizarre argument to make but most radically felt in the english-speaking world yeah so i thought i knew you'd make this argument
我认为最终也被证明是一个比许多人预期要保守得多的政治人物。总的来说，我要说法国在政治上发生的情况是，那种英国或不如说是英国的中间偏左人士往往会理想化法国，并想象这是一个类似于社会民主主义的天堂。但实际上我要说，法国在很多方面是一个非常保守的国家。我的意思是，仅举CRS（法国防暴警察）的例子，CRS在有一点抗议迹象时仍然会冲出去把人的脑袋打破。是的，但你可以提出这样一个论点，即68年5月的实际影响——我的意思是，这听起来可能是一个奇怪的论点——最深刻地感受于英语世界，是的——所以我想我知道你会提出这个论点，
which is why i went hard on the on the alternative so we talked about foucault in the first part of he's been away but he does come back so i think you i think you do have a sense in the wake of 68 that a lot of the kind of the celebrated french philosophers yeah derrida and lacan and yeah julia christieva and but most famously foucault yeah i'm trying to wonder why did it go wrong why did nothing happen and foucault gets very interested in kind of prisons the state apparatus for repression surveillance surveillance so the famous image that he comes up with in his book, Discipline and Punish, as it's translated into English, comes out in 1975, is this idea, it's actually English, so Jeremy Bentham.
这就是为什么我在另一个替代观点上立场坚定。所以在第一部分我们谈到了福柯，他曾一度离开，但他确实回来了，所以我认为你确实会有这样一种感觉：在68年之后，许多著名的法国哲学家——是的，德里达、拉康、茱莉亚·克里斯蒂娃，以及最著名的福柯——是的，我在纳闷为什么事情会出错，为什么什么都没发生，而福柯对监狱、国家镇压机器、监控制度产生了浓厚的兴趣。因此他在1975年出版的英语译本《规训与惩罚》中提出了一个著名的概念，这个想法其实源自英国人杰里米·边沁。
Yeah, the panopticon. The idea that the state is always watching you. So a prison where you are always being surveyed. And he advances the theory that the state constructs these apparatuses to generate what he calls docile bodies yeah so in other words everything that within a state is structured to geld and pacify the revolutionary spirit yes and you you might think that this is exactly the kind of thing the french would go for but i think you're right that by and large foucault is regarded as a bit of a charlatan in france that actually it's in british university no it's in america really it's in america because
是的，全景监狱。国家随时都在监视你的想法。所以这是一个你时刻受到监视的监狱。他提出了这样一个理论：国家构建这些机器是为了产生他所谓的“驯顺的身体”，是的，换句话说，国家内部的一切结构都是为了阉割和抚平革命精神，是的，你可能会认为这正是法国人会喜欢的那种东西，但我认为你是对的，大体上福柯在法国被视为有点江湖骗子，实际上它是在英国大学——不，它其实是在美国，因为
in america in as i don't need to tell you in the 70s intellectuals likewise particularly on the left are wondering well what the hell happened how have we ended up with nixon how have we ended up with ford that's very cruel to gerald ford and so they they apply this kind of insight to what they see as the apparatus of repression and i mean america is jailing a lot of people and they're they're often black yeah and so that then feeds into theories about intersectionality and so on that then the possessions with power and oppression power and oppression all the time which which then had a kind of huge impact in 2020 with yeah with um with the black lives matter protests which in a way it has a kind of 68 feel i think well there's an argument isn't it that the spirit of 68 became institutionalized because basically the mime artists and polo necks ended up running cultural
在美国，正如我无需提醒你的那样，在70年代，知识分子同样尤其是左翼知识分子在纳闷，到底发生了什么？我们怎么会弄出个尼克松？怎么会弄出个福特？——对杰拉尔德·福特太残忍了——所以他们将这种洞察力应用到他们所看到的镇压机器上，我的意思是，美国正在把很多人关进监狱，而且他们通常是黑人，是的，这就引发了关于交叉性等理论，然后是对权力和压迫的痴迷，权力和压迫无处不在，这在2020年产生了巨大影响，比如“黑人的命也是命”抗议活动，某种程度上它有一种68年的感觉，我认为。好吧，有一个论点不是吗，68年的精神被体制化了，因为基本上那些哑剧演员和穿高领毛衣的人最终去管理了文化
institutions but they're all bourgeois yeah yeah they are of course they are i mean that's the sort of the standard story is of the 68er who just ends up selling out and becoming you know a university bureaucrat or something and i think all of those people i mean effectively they did end up with the levers of cultural power and from the 1980s but i think in in say in the united states or in britain the idea of things like institutional racism, the idea that there are structures that are inherently repressive. Yeah. I think you could trace the origins of that philosophy back to Foucault and back to the way that Foucault is trying to make sense of 68.
机构，但他们全都是资产阶级，是的，他们当然是，我的意思是，那是一种标准的说法，关于68年的人最终背叛了自己的理想，变成了一个大学官僚什么的，我认为所有这些人——我的意思是，实际上他们确实在20世纪80年代最终掌握了文化权力的杠杆，但我认为，比如说在美国或英国，诸如体制性种族主义之类的想法、认为存在本质上具有压迫性的结构的想法，是的，我认为你可以把这种哲学的根源追溯到福柯，以及福柯试图理解68年的方式上。
Maybe I'm over-egging it. So I think the claims that are made for the influence of 1968 are, well, you know, they lost on the streets, as it were. They lost in the legislative elections, but they won in the long run. They won the battle for culture that are individualistic. Are we talking about France here? France and the West generally, I would say. But I think all of those changes, and in fact, even those arguments about power and oppression and so on,
也许我有点言过其实了。所以我认为人们对1968年影响的宣称是——嗯，你知道的，他们可以说是在街头失败了，他们在立法选举中失败了，但从长远来看他们赢了。他们赢得了文化之战，那些文化是个体主义的。我们这里是在谈论法国吗？可以说既有法国，也有广义的西方。但我认为所有这些变化，事实上，甚至那些关于权力和压迫的争论等等，
I think they would have happened even if the students at Nanterre had been able to visit the other people's halls of residence. I don't think it took the street protests and then the moment of excitement to, I think it's slightly false self-congratulation. Well, I know you love to diss this philosophy. I think you can see that
我认为即使楠泰尔的学生们没有去过别人的宿舍，这些事情也还是会发生。我不认为这需要街头抗议和那一刻的兴奋来促成，我认为这有点虚假的自我祝贺。好吧，我知道你喜欢贬低这种哲学，但我想你可以看到
there is a kind of intellectual influence there. And I think also what's interesting is that it does also influence conservatism. Because famously, a British student in May 1968 who looks out of the window at the students ripping up the cobblestones is Roger Scruton. Yes. Who becomes, I mean, he's probably not an influential figure in Britain, but he's a massively influential figure for conservatives in Europe. I mean, he's a huge influence on victor orban yeah on george particularly in eastern europe yeah i mean and yeah because what did he say middle-class hooligans yeah what i saw was an unruly mob of middle-class hooligans when i asked my friends what they wanted all i got back was
其中确实存在某种知识分子层面的影响。而且我也认为有趣的是，它对保守主义也产生了影响。因为众所周知，1968年5月一个从窗户看着学生们撬开鹅卵石的英国学生就是罗吉·斯克鲁顿。是的。他成为了——我的意思是，他在英国可能不是一个很有影响力的人物，但对于欧洲的保守派来说，他是一个极具影响力的人物。我的意思是，他是维克托·欧尔班的巨大影响来源，是的，对乔治也是，特别是在东欧，是的，我的意思是——是的，因为他是怎么说的？中产阶级暴徒？是的，我看到的是一群不守规矩的中产阶级暴徒。当我问我的朋友们他们想要什么时，我得到的只有
ludicrous marxist gobbledygook so that's from his essay why i became a conservative and what roger scrutin does in that essay is he contrasts it with Prague about the experience of going to the Czechoslovakia. Because that's going on at the same time, isn't it? So to my mind actually,
荒谬的马克思主义胡言乱语。所以这出自他的文章《我为什么成为保守派》。而罗吉·斯克鲁顿在那篇文章中所做的是，他将其与布拉格、去捷克斯洛伐克的经历进行了对比。因为那也在同时发生，不是吗？所以在我的脑海里，实际上，
for people in Britain in particular where there is no real 1968, the events of May 1968 in Paris seem so exciting, intoxicating, indelibly French, a sign of all the things that are fun and romantic and glamorous about France,
对英国人来说，特别是当那里没有真正的1968年时，巴黎1968年5月的事件显得如此激动人心、令人陶醉、带有不可磨灭的法国色彩，它是法国所有有趣、浪漫和迷人之处的象征，
whereas we in Britain are, you know, driving to and from Milton Keynes or whatever. But actually, in the grand scheme of things, they are eclipsed massively by what happened in Prague. Which is very, very devastating for the moral claims of the Soviet Union and the auto pact and probably communism generally yeah so the mexico olympics there is a terrible massacre in mexico
而我们英国人则在开车去米尔顿凯恩斯或别的地方。但实际上，从宏大的历史格局来看，它们被布拉格发生的事情彻底黯然失色了。这对于苏联、华约组织以及整个共产主义的道德主张来说是极其毁灭性的，是的，所以墨西哥奥运会，墨西哥城发生了一场可怕的大屠杀，
city which is you know kind of eclipsed in the popular imagination um dozens i think maybe even hundreds of people are massacred and again one of these events of this extraordinary year or indeed in america tom so when martin luther king is assassinated i think we talked about this already i think something like 43 people die in the riots that follow in the the police versus rioters in american cities again by those standards do the events of may 1968 in paris exciting and dramatic and spectacular as they are do they really as we discussed in our episode with Christopher Clarke on the revolutions of 1848, it's because it's Paris.
这在公众想象中被淡化了，嗯，几十人，我想甚至数百人被屠杀，再次成为这个非凡年份的事件之一，或者在美利坚，汤姆，当马丁·路德·金被暗杀时，我想我们已经讨论过这个了，随之而来的骚乱中大约有43人死亡，美国城市中的警察对阵暴徒，再次以这些标准来看，巴黎1968年5月的事件——尽管它们令人兴奋、戏剧化且壮观——正如我们在与克里斯托弗·克拉克讨论1848年革命的那期节目中所讨论的，那是因为它是巴黎。
It's because Paris is the home of revolution. It is. The French Revolution is the primal example of this. And so whatever happens in Paris reverberates across the world. But is this not the last time that ever happened? Don't you think? It seems so.
那是因为巴黎是革命的发源地。确实是的。法国大革命是这方面的原始范例。因此，无论巴黎发生什么，都会在全世界产生共鸣。但难道这不是最后一次发生这种情况吗？你不这么觉得吗？看起来确实如此。
I mean, France has really swung to the right. I agree. Because don't you think that I said in the first episode, I think that this was the most exciting moment in kind of post-war French history. But actually it's the only moment in French history that most people outside France, in modern French history, have ever heard of.
我的意思是，法国确实向右翼大幅倾转。我同意。因为难道你不觉得——我在第一集里说过，我认为这是战后法国历史中最激动人心的时刻。但实际上，它是法国以外绝大多数人所听说的现代法国历史中唯一的时刻。
Because what's happened since then, the Mitterrand presidency, the Chirac presidency, Sarkozy, Hollande, Macron, france in modern french history have ever heard of because what's happened since then the mitoan presidency the sherat presidency sarkozy holland macron i don't think anybody outside france could name a single event that happened in any of those presidencies because actually i mean obviously there have been riots um since 1968 so there was some very very serious urban writing in 2005 that's right i remember 2012 again but they were largely children of immigrants out on the banlieue, the peripherique. And there were kind of soissons-huitards who were trying to speak the language of 68 when they analyzed this. But actually, it meant nothing to the people
因为自那以后发生的事情——密特朗总统任期、希拉克总统任期、萨科齐、奥朗德、马克龙，法国在现代法国历史中——自那以后发生的事情包括密特朗总统任期、希拉克总统任期、萨科齐、奥朗德、马克龙，我认为法国以外的任何人都不可能说出在这些总统任期内发生的任何单一事件，因为实际上——显然自1968年以来有过骚乱，所以2005年有过非常非常严重的城市骚乱，没错，我记得2012年也是，但它们主要是在郊区（banlieue）、外环路（peripherique）上的移民后代。当他们分析这些时，有些所谓的“老八八人”（soixante-huitards）试图使用68年的语言。但实际上，这对于
who were rioting in 2005. I mean, the language of the revolution and of soissons-huitards meant nothing to the people who were rioting in 2005 i mean the language of the revolution and of special wheat meant nothing to them and actually maybe tom you could say here we are in 2023 you know we're probably the last generation that could make this podcast on this subject and think it's a really big interesting subject because don't you think in generations to come these events will dwindle compared with 1848 with the parents you know, I mean, 1968 as a year still has a kind of glamour. It definitely does. I think it's
在2005年参与骚乱的人来说毫无意义，我的意思是，革命的语言和老八八人的语言对于2005年骚乱的人来说毫无意义，而且也许汤姆你可以说，我们现在身处2023年，你知道，我们可能是最后一代能够制作一档关于这个主题的播客，并认为这是一个非常重大且有趣的课题的人了，因为你不认为在未来的世世代代中，这些事件与1848年相比将会逐渐黯然失色吗？你知道的，我的意思是，1968年作为一年依然有一种魅力。确实如此。我认为那是
Che Guevara, Martin Luther King. Yeah, Robert Kennedy. Exactly. And the music as well. So the music of
切·格瓦拉，马丁·路德·金。是的。罗伯特·肯尼迪。完全正确。还有音乐。所以
1968, I think, provides a soundtrack to it. And Richard Nixon, Tom. Let's not forget, I always like to remind people that
1968年的音乐，我认为，为它提供了背景配乐。还有理查德·尼克松，汤姆。我们不要忘记，我总是喜欢提醒人们，
the big winner of 1968 is Richard Nixon. That's how I like to pop it. That's what makes me so popular at dinner parties. Yes.
1968年的最大赢家是理查德·尼克松。我就是喜欢这样语出惊人。这就是为什么我在晚宴上这么受欢迎。是的。
Right. So we will return to 1968, I think, next year, because we're going to, for the American presidential election, I have all kinds of great notions at my sleeve about American presidential elections, and 1968 is the canonical one. But also, I think we will return to France, the subject of France, in due course, because we have to finish the French off in the Hundred Years' War. We do. And we've talked a lot about the French Revolution.
好的。所以我们将在明年重返1968年，我想，因为我们将要——为了美国总统大选，我袖子里藏着关于美国总统大选的各种好主意，而1968年是典范。而且我也认为，我们将在适的时候重返法国、重返法国这个主题，因为我们必须在《百年战争》中把法国人了结。我们确实要这样做。而且我们已经谈了很多关于法国大革命的事。
Yeah. And we're aware that we've only, we've done two episodes on the events of May 1968. We've done one episode on the whole of the French Revolution. So we must maybe come back to Paris. We have loads of French history. And if we do come back to Paris, then we will know what card
是的。我们意识到我们只做过两期关于1968年5月事件的节目。我们只做了一期关于整个法国大革命的节目。所以我们可能必须回到巴黎。我们有大量的法国历史。如果我们回到巴黎，那么我们就知道该带什么卡
and what app to bring. Remind me, Tom, I've forgotten. So, we've been using Wise and Wise brilliantly have created a travel guide to Paris that includes lots of the locations
以及什么应用程序了。提醒我一下，汤姆，我忘了。所以，我们一直在使用Wise，而Wise非常出色地制作了一份巴黎旅游指南，其中包含了我们在今天的节目中谈到的许多地点。我的意思是，当然谈到了香榭丽舍大街，我们现在离它不远，我们正坐在那里。因此，要了解更多关于如何像
we've talked about in today's episode. I mean, certainly talks about the Champs-Élysées, we're not far from that now, where we're sitting. And so to learn more about how you can travel
多米尼克·桑德布鲁克这位伟大的历史学家一样旅行，却能像一个巴黎人一样消费的信息，你可以访问wise.com斜杠restishistory或者点击
like Dominic Sandbrook, a great historian, and yet spend like a Parisian, you can visit wise.com slash restishistory or click the link
今天节目简介中的链接。带着这个话题，汤姆，我现在就要去香榭丽舍大街买个纪念品了。你知道我要买什么吗？我要买一个小埃菲尔铁塔。
in today's episode description. And on that note, Tom, I'm going to go off down the Champs-Élysées right now to buy a souvenir. Do you know what I'm going to buy? I'm going to buy a little Eiffel Tower.
是吗？对。你不会去买一块鹅卵石吧？不，我要买什么？我要买一个小埃菲尔铁塔。是吗？对。你不会去买一块鹅卵石吧？不。拿它去砸防暴警察。
Are you? Yeah. You're not going to buy a chunk of cobblestones? No'm going to buy? I'm going to buy a little Eiffel Tower. Are you? Yeah. You're not going to buy a chunk of cobblestones? No. Chuck it as a riot policeman.
我其实可能会买个小的，看看他们有没有戴高乐将军的塑像之类的。你当然会。带着这个重磅消息，
I might actually buy a little, see if they've got a General de Gaulle effigy or something like that. Of course you are. On that bombshell,
我们说“谢谢，再见”（Merci et au revoir）。再见（Au revoir）。本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
we say merci et au revoir. Au revoir. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们说谢谢并再见。再见。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。